and he'll get it back on the far side you saw
Corella make the push all the way over to stop
mdon there's a shot score spots that that
puck can find its way through sub look hang
on it SL shot himself all the way around Val
fell down but kept it alive finds Taves out
mckin fake the onetime fre shot he scores
back it goes for Jer with the dot steered
it up save by goria but it chipped right across
him set up to the Blue Line rammed off for giru
in the slot shot same bu with the left toe of
his left back and he has clear it down here's
McKinnon looking for his fourth you're BR heon
score Nathan M Kennon it's a four goal night and
the Avalanche withand withstand and withstand
they've taken a 64 lead and oh baby they came
roaring back in the third to win this one and
gorv just continues to stand on his head big
gr kachuck comes out of the corner gorv just
stays with it makes it look easy had a couple
other point blank read in the hash marks and
then here it is D McKinnon to cap off a four
goal fivepoint night he just continues his amazing
play and is now within four points of the league
lead in the National Hockey League on a 17 game
point streak all you can say about number 29 is
wow the avales with three goals in the third
four unanswered to take a 6-4 lead overall